[Music]
back in our more socially ambitious
years christian and i would go to vegas
a lot
vegas baby we were at an opening of some
cirque du soleil show they were having
some like after party thing that we
and we just went to because we're like
we got to show up at this thing and
we're supposed to meet neil patrick
harris upstairs so we said to the
bouncer and he just sounded arrogant but
we thought we were on a list and we
weren't do you mind if we just run up we
have to tell our friend we were like
name dropped neils and we were like we
have to sell our friend neil patrick
harris just that we came and we couldn't
get in so as chris and i are waiting off
to the side at one point there was a
huge stream of people like a parade of
like girls and miniskirts and like
kind of douchey looking guys and like
tight shirts and stuff and leading this
group was
carrot top and the bouncer was like oh
right this way
uh carrot and all his
all his friends were going in and we're
i'm looking at him carrot top and he
sees me and he kind of he comes over and
he quickly assesses the situation sees
that we can't get into this club and he
goes hey man you want to come be in our
in my basically into my entourage in my
group so karen tried to get us into this
club so later on in the night justin was
like kind of to himself almost he was
like i can't believe carrot top tried to
get us into a club tonight like that's
such a crazy story
and i was like
what do you mean carrot top tried to get
us into a club when did that happen i
said that guy that came over when we
were waiting that he was like that was
carrots
justin was like who do you think it was
yeah who looks like carrot top who looks
like airtight and i kept referring to
him as carrot and to this day i'm not
convinced
[Music]
life could be a dream sweetheart
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long and with me as
always is um my non-ginger non-magician
talent magically inclined non-uh ripped
ripped
christian my brother non-prop comedian
oh yeah he's a prop guy isn't he or
maybe is that insulting no he is a prop
comic isn't he yeah i think he is or am
i getting him confused with gallagher
like no gallagher i think specifically
smashes things no i think gallagher
that's insulting to gallagher i think
gallagher does a lot of [ __ ]
to all the gala i'm not saying he
smashes a lot of [ __ ] i think he uses a
lot of props i think that's his thing
all the gallagher nerds
um he does but his his famous bit is
smashing a watermelon that's what he's
saying that's true that's famous but
it's like you'd say about jim gaffigan
his famous bid is the hot pocket but he
does a lot more than that
uh anyway carrot top nothing again he
was actually he was really nice really
nice i just thought he was a really nice
stranger i didn't know he was character
i don't know how you don't
recognize that face well you know in my
defense i think carrot top from when we
were kids
has gone through such a physical
metamorphosis
that uh i just didn't mean i had
i hadn't been accustomed to save it for
the character i hadn't been a it would
be great to have it
um i just i think my brain hadn't caught
up to his the new reality of carrot top
so i still pictured him as a kind of
like a scrawny like big you know red
hair but he looks so different now yeah
that's right when we were kids he was
like a scrawny he was carrot top he was
like sideshow bob or something yes yeah
yeah now he's he got really ripped i
would love to talk to him actually and
you know when you make fun of me for my
eyebrows like spazzing i think his
eyebrows always kind of look like that
yeah now yeah like evil he's like an
evil he's like a evil face but
couldn't have been nicer no uh yeah i
know i was uh i was very thankful it was
also just funny that like
carrot top tried to get us it's a funny
it's a funny sound bite
remember that time the carrot top got us
into a club no no try
well yeah i had the intention of getting
this whole entourage speaking of
entourage yes ready for this segway oh
yeah i'm glad you're sitting down for
this
our guest today is not karate
it is someone who was uh on a very
famous show called entourage
and she was
the female face i would say of that show
that i would even call it an iconic show
yeah uh entourage yes yeah uh our guest
day is the wonderful kind so kind guy um
emmanuel shrieky warm she's many things
she's many good things she is i i
haven't seen any bad things she's not as
far as i know only um good thing we
talked about our if there are any bad
things and uh
you know she certainly didn't reveal any
um as you're about to find out but uh
yeah entourage is a show that was on for
many years on hbo and it's something
that i just recently started re-watching
because i worked with uh the director
one of the the guy who directed most of
the episodes of the first season and
second season julian farino a little
plug from a new netflix show uh but he
directed this
this netflix bbc series that i um and
that's coming out this fall called jiri
[ __ ] one of the nicest people i've ever
worked for one of the
kindest directors um sensitive and
really good really great director and he
did most of those entourage episodes i
think was before emmanuel came on i
think her character came on in the
second or third season but she was on
for many years uh we emanuel and i have
worked together a number of times
and she's just one of my favorite people
you got to know her
very well doing a movie called
originally called patriot bill that got
uh they got changed to called taking
chances they changed the title to from
patriot bill
to taking
chances
which i think is uh
if this is possible an even dumber movie
title than literally right before aaron
which i make fun of on every single
podcast
but the movie but the title taking
chances is yeah does it get dumber than
that uh no we talked about this a lot of
christian likes to say it's the most
it's hard to imagine a more generic
title and we try to sometimes like um
things things happened
characters interact
yeah
different people who know each other
learning lessons
yeah learning lessons well there are
some that that exist most of them exist
most titles exist yeah but but also
patriot bill is kind of a cool title i
think well taking chances is not a
perfect title for any movie because it
doesn't say anything specific but see
that's what they wanted that's what
happens
when somebody take when a company then
takes over a little fun
product like that like patriot but it
was it was made in the spirit of like
real indie movie making and it was a
sweet little movie and then it got
bought and of course the people who
bought it want to make money and so they
want to package it a certain way so they
packaged it to be like this very generic
appeal to as many people as possible
well then they picked the perfect title
yeah taking chance and the perfect if
you see well maybe we'll post a photo of
the
cover because it's
funny it's very and they photoshopped
little playing cards in my hands and i
have this look like this like befuddled
look on my face it's really embarrassing
so and offensive and they made emanuel
wear this like little mini skirt and
like this like little sexy i mean better
her wearing it than you i guess
yeah but i it was great to see her i i
hadn't seen her in a couple years um and
she's just had such good energy she
really does have great energy you can
feel it just listening to it yeah um but
uh
yeah it was fun to see her and i know it
was fun for you to catch up with her so
you won't this won't tran you won't get
this from the interview but uh there are
she
speaking we'll talk we'll talk okay okay
okay
um but uh it was really great to see her
i i know you had a good time talking to
her catching up with her i really did
and i hope all of you
enjoy maybe hearing from her for the
first time or
again if it's been a while
um so this is it the conversation that
justin had with emmanuel shriki
life could be a dream
you are easily the best person that i
know um in terms of making a space your
own and like comfortable you would know
yeah i would know so emm and i did a
movie called which everyone probably
knows that it was
it was laughing because nobody saw it
it's called it was called patriot ville
at the time and it's about
it was about a a plucky but then it
changed the names right yeah so they
changed it it was about a kid a kid a
guy a man boy who
who is really into the history of his
small town and um
you were like you were in a grifter you
lived there i lived there i was some
offbeat you were not you're quirky
yeah eccentric we had like a romance in
it but it was um and you helped me kind
of like save this i can't believe people
didn't see it
you helped me save this whatever the the
battle had taken place on this land and
you helped me restore it by the way can
we just say that that was one of the
greatest experiences well that's the
thing about these movies that i'm i may
i'm like making light of the movie
because nobody saw it wasn't a great
movie but it was so [ __ ] fun it was
so what rock hill
south carolina yeah so we were in rocky
hill and that was closest to charlotte
we flew into charlotte north carolina
and it was just over the border in south
carolina and we spent
we got to know a lot of that there was a
college there we got to know a lot of
the the kids we went back and partied
unfortunately
you yeah yeah i shouldn't say we you
were very responsible and but we would
party in these in fact we had a friend
uh christine
uh wardrobe supervisor on remember
christine
but anyway christine was of asian
descent
uh but she was from like encino you know
she was like totally yeah yeah she's a
california girl and um we had been
hanging out with these local college
guys like bros and um they were totally
nice you know and they said one night
christine wasn't with us she was part of
our little like group and she just
hadn't happened to not be there and one
of these guys goes hey man where's your
uh where's that chinese gal
and i was like but what he goes you know
that chinese guy you're always hanging
out with and i'd swear i didn't know who
she was talking anyway
i said because you know she and then he
described her a little bit like you
would describe you know she wearing that
camo jacket and i said oh christine and
i said yeah oh christine's not trying
she's from he goes yeah whatever yeah
whatever
you know that asian bra but wait but jay
this is like i think it was the same
night and you were out with these people
and you ended up going to like some
really nice house somewhere and then you
i'll never forget this i've told this
story so many times and then you said
wow
this is a really nice house who lives
here and one of the college students was
like well i don't know like
some jew
[Laughter]
now we should also clarify that many of
them many of the people we met down
there were not anti-semitic or racist
many of them were very we didn't mean
yeah
we just happened to hang out with the
ones yeah that was true but he said it
so again the same way the guy said the
chinese thing he said it's so in so
matter-of-factly like not just some
without any he didn't couch it with any
like embarrassment or like as a jew you
know it was like just some jew just like
proudly um but that was uh we also i
mean i'm not proud of this again i've
i've grown
i'm older i don't really like to stay
out anymore um i i that's saying that
we're older yeah i can't um but we'd go
out so late that um
the dp the director of photography came
to us at one point and this keep in mind
this is the guy that shot all of larry
clark's movies so he shot kids and bully
and like he came to us and he goes guys
um
i'm having a hard time lighting
you have to maybe take it easy you got
to chill out because we were just awful
like we look like zombies we we're crazy
do you remember our trip too yeah
uh isle of palms isle of palms yeah so
it's right off the coast of south
carolina it's beautiful it's by the way
that whole coast is
stunning it's stunning yeah we were
there with a friend because the funny
part to me of that trip is that emm and
i were um
we were smoking weed is that saying i
can cut out anything you want we were
smoking we and we were pretty stoned but
it was the mo and we were right on the
ocean and the waves
amazing it was such a great place to
just be stoned and kind of like check in
with your surroundings and our friend
who we were with who shall remain
nameless um was
to decide his drug of choice their drug
of choice was cocaine
so it was such a crazy juxtaposition it
was like emma and i were just like
what is happening right now and he'd
come in and be like you guys oh my god
the waves are [ __ ] crazy right holy
[ __ ]
it was just such different energies um
how do you do that when you when you
travel like how do you move your because
we were in a in a holiday inn it was a
fairly modest little hotel yeah how did
you do that i've always wondered that i
i'd walk into your room and it was like
it was like an oasis
what was it called uh holiday it was a
holiday that's a song
oasis holidays
um you know what babe it's so it's so
simple i think like the the idea that
you know we go into these super generic
spaces where there's been like a million
people and you know me i'm like super
sensitive to energy so i'm like i need
to clear this space and i need to make
it my own and it's so you know some
incense of music some candles and it's
because you think that's what it's at
the heart of it because of the the
people the existence the lives that had
been lived in there maybe once a certain
amount for sure and i think that when
you know you know you're gonna go and be
somewhere for an extended period of time
yeah it's like you just bring
the little comforts that make you feel
good so that when you walk in and you're
like ugh i always forget about that if i
have friends over i've had people who
stay stayed in my places and
i always get a little squeamish about
them like i know they're probably if
they might [ __ ] on the bed on my bed you
know i think like i'm a little bit i'm a
germaphobe but then for some reason when
i stay at hotels i don't often consider
the amount of [ __ ] and like not like
good sensual like salmon king [ __ ]
you know not like nine and a half weeks
it's like not that that's good i don't
want people dripping food on each other
amazing but like awful like you know um
anyway we won't dwell on that but so so
the movie we did was called patriot
originally and it was a sweet little
whatever oh rename taking chances yes so
they renamed it to take in case anybody
wants to see yeah well i don't i
wouldn't even know where to find it to
tune in
they play it cons on hbo
um it's they're doing a revival of it
they're releasing they're doing a
limited release uh but taking chances i
my christian and i laugh about it
because we think it's the it's the most
generic it's hard to think of a more
generic title
just for a movie than taking chances
yeah um we thought of a few uh things
happen
the plot unfolds
what's around the corner you know it's
just so like
that's good that could describe any
movie but i mean that was the thing is
that initially we had this such a cute
quirky like true
spirited indie film it was you know what
i mean like it really was talmage who
directed it really cared about it
so
much and then it was like they wanted to
commercialize it well they repackaged it
i remember because it had taken a while
yes
so adam and i showed up for a photo
shoot and to to we were like oh cool
some distributor bought it they're going
to release it and um now we're gonna
like do a photo shoot for the cup for a
cover
and we showed up and you're what were
you wearing in the movie you play you
really do play this like quirky kind of
like oddball yeah girl and i i as did i
play guy was obsessed with history so my
wardrobe when i showed up was like a
leather jacket and like tight those you
know those jeans that had like fake
fading on them and like this and grows
like
um and you were wearing some i mean it
looked great but like not the character
at all
no i know and i remember too at that
photo shoot you were like
you refused
to take one of these oh right so we were
laughing about like what poses they
wanted us to do and at one point i
jokingly was jokingly was like oh do you
want us to do the old back-to-back like
what about this guy
as a joke and she goes in fact she goes
yes that's actually the the one that
they specifically requested
and we were like oh [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] but and they did they
repackaged it and they photoshopped or
whatever it was just
but you had just done when they marketed
it i had done he's just nothing into and
you had done zohan you can you know you
don't mess with the zohan so i i think
they were trying to make it just like a
capitalized yeah
on the our huge
successes um you were born in uh
montreal but raised in toronto at what
point did you go to toronto do you
remember do you have memories of
montreal i do well
because i spent so much time there my
sister still lives there so growing up i
went there but i left when i was two so
she still lives there yeah oh wow and
you're fluent in french and you've done
you've worked in french
did uh
i did a french film about five years ago
a romantic comedy um
translated it was called taking chances
it was called um
love situation it's complicated that's
the translation that might be a more
generic title than taking changes yeah
it might be
but you know what can i just say that
was one of
my
highlight experiences like if somebody
says to me
if you go back in time if you go back in
time i'm gonna say that if you go back
in time right now
paris five years ago
yes what about it
i mean besides being in paris i mean it
was being in paris it was living in the
marie for two and a half months in this
beautiful apartment it was
shooting in french
working with europeans you weren't
intimidated
because you don't speak the language of
you probably were maybe a little rusty i
totally was but by the end it was like
rediscovering
a very very
real part of who i am yeah like it was
like the
suddenly i was just this french girl i
was like oh but this is so familiar to
me it's so deep because your parents
both spoke it yeah at home yeah you know
and i resisted speaking it growing up
and so
learning the part
it was terrifying
you know because all the things of like
you know you read a script you break
down a script in english we don't think
about it in french i'm just like oh my
god
what so
daunting and all the other actors i'm
guessing were french totally
but i was so well taken care of and i
was so supported and literally like by
the end
i just i felt like a little french girl
yeah yeah it was epic well it i wonder
if too psychologically it tied you back
you know it brought you back
to a time when you were with your
parents yeah justin that's so
well that was such a part of the
emotional experience for me like it was
just like wow like this one i mean like
this is
absolutely a big part of who i am yeah
and i'm guessing you had a really like
lovely childhood you're such a love i
mean i say that only because you're
such a
warm kind person i'm guessing that came
from somewhere and and you know
i don't imagine you overcame
much but i know you went through a lot
of tragedy what was your upbringing like
what was your childhood i mean
you know
i i had yes
i had a great childhood um maybe i got
it wrong no no no no assumption you
didn't get it wrong i think
i had a great childhood it wasn't a
perfect childhood i think you know
and loosely you know i
i i dealt as you know i lost both of my
parents but i lost my mom when i was
quite young
and she was young she was only 48 years
old like that's so [ __ ] nuts
do you know what i mean well especially
now that we're approaching that yes and
it must be even it must hit you even it
does because i don't know about you but
i don't feel i remember when i was when
back then i hear 48 and like that sounds
kind of old but now it's wow you're like
wait that's so young in the corner i
know
so
so
the sort of
answer to your question is that
yes my childhood was amazing i think
my mom you know i think i think we
talked about this a long time ago my mom
was there was a lot of anxiety at home
and she had quite a temper
so it was really
it was jarring because she was the one
who gave so much love and she was also
the one who
instilled a lot of
there were conditions though huh so many
yeah so many and then add on top of that
you know a pretty traditional jewish
home they were orthodox the modern
orthodox you know kosher at home shabbat
like the high holidays which now i'm
like thank god i have that because it's
such a gift yeah so it's something that
you've continued a tradition that you've
continued for sure yeah yeah and i think
in a way really to honor them
like it's a way to just sort of
celebrate what i grew up with so was
your dad more of a a grounding force was
he more of a kind of calming force for
your mom and for you well
i wish that were the case daddy was um
daddy was
i mean he wouldn't hurt a fly he was the
softest most gentle funny
he
was known for his smile for his laughter
for his jokes for his like easy way
but you know sadly that didn't always
translate at home yeah um but yes did i
have a happy childhood yes i grew up in
canada i never wanted for anything you
started acting at a
fairly early age right when you were a
kid you were a child yeah um and was
that after your mom passed away yeah
exactly but i did theater since i was
seven oh you did uh-huh do you miss
doing theater
i had stage freight oh oh no did you
know that no yeah no
stage fright pretty intensely really but
yes i do miss theater what happens to
you i pack panic attacks and stuff i do
i get i get so anxious and i ask myself
what the [ __ ] am i doing i know i you
know it's fine i have a version of that
for sure yeah but everyone can i think
so except that some people can get
through it a lot easier like
i just have that awful actors nightmare
of like what happens if i forget
everything that's the worst and
sometimes it like
but when i'm on stage i'm like oh but
wait this is the greatest thing ever i
know i know so i feel like i'll i'll do
it again at the right time
the right thing neil patrick harris was
on and i asked him how
what's going through your head before
because he had alluded to having you
know he gets anxiety yeah so before you
host the oscars like what is in your
head like what are you just freaking out
your stomachers i'm
kind of like projecting all the things
that i would feel like and he was like
no i'm i'm pretty good to go
he said it happens um
it happens earlier than that but right
before he goes on stage i i still get it
i just did a play in new york i'm like
what am i doing why am i doing this
really
yeah it got it but then as soon as the
you know curtain goes up it's weird
something magic
yeah do you struggle with anxiety yes
yeah i was talking about this yesterday
once it didn't go away when the curtain
came up and it was because i
i'm gonna sound like such a lush this is
awesome guys i'm not like this anymore
this is like eight years ago
it was broadway too and i
had gone out the night before
because i thought oh
we're on it's on its feet now we're in
into shows now i can like go out and
have a drink
i drank too much and uh
the next night it wasn't we didn't have
a matinee so i thought i have all day to
recover
and around seven o'clock i started i was
still hungover and i started feeling i
was still kind of queasy
yeah we were on stage and the curtain
was about to go up and there's a
protocol um
if you're not feeling well or
something's wrong you have to save the
stage manager
you got to hold the curtain something
you know and then you get to go to the
bathroom or like get your stand in to do
it
so i was um i said to the stage manager
i i can't do i think i'm gonna throw up
something's wrong and he was like um we
already made the announcement i'm so
sorry
and so i was stuck i was stuck on stage
and uh oh my god i just got this oh oh
it's horrible and i start
now i'm panicking
curtains going up now i'm just thinking
and i have so many lines in this first
scene i have so much to do in the scene
and it's jeff goldblum's
our teacher and it's about all these
other great actors on stage and i'm like
fall [ __ ] i'm
i i have to figure out when i'm going to
run off stage to puke oh my god and so
i'm trying to figure out okay how when
do i have a few lines off so i can go
through come back and um oh it was awful
it was the worst and i couldn't i was
like oh i can't remember any lines i'm
just
figuring i'm just trying to figure out
what i'm gonna puke then the lines were
just kind of come out of my mouth and i
was like oh thank god thank god that
happened but now i don't remember the
next one but then the next one will come
out yeah and it went like that
throughout the whole first scene and
after that scene i was okay and at the
end of the play i was so grateful to
have gotten through it and i said to
somebody in the cast they i was like i i
think i must have looked odd at the end
i was like maybe even like emotional
like tyrion and
they said are you okay with and i said
yeah did you my friend zoe i said did
you notice anything
weird about that performance because i i
gotta tell you i was like not myself and
she goes no you seem fine except for
that first scene you were like gray and
sweating bullets
you're just really gray and sweaty um
yeah i get it it's it's awful it's
terrible and with so with film you never
experience that you never feel have
there been experience you know moments
where you're with adam sandler or some
big deal where you're like god oh you
know what fame it's so crazy that you
should ask this question i don't know
that in that way no like i think
you know for example working with adam
there was one day there that i was on
set and it was adam
sandler john turturro
and rob schneider
and myself
and i was like what did i do to deserve
this yeah
you feel lucky yeah i felt so lucky
and supported i think that's such a huge
thing i think when you feel supported
you do
your best work your confidence is there
and it's it's when you feel like
everyone's like edgy and nervous and
you're like yes i don't know what's
happening this is you don't mess with
this over the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you don't yes i'm jumping
around a lot adam i heard his sets are
like
the best they're just really loose
they're amazing and it's so crazy
because you know with adam
everybody gets this idea that it's like
so loose and chill and they're watching
but it's not like adam is
and has created what he created because
he's such a professional
and he's kind of a perfectionist how
interesting
and well there wasn't a lot of improv
like those jokes
were written really really i think
because it was controversial in a lot of
ways you're talking about israeli and
palestinians they were like
they really thought about those jokes i
bet i rewatched it recently and it it is
kind of like um way ahead of its i don't
think it's
anyone's tried to do anything like that
since um
i mean they're a joke all the jokes are
about the jews and the israelis and the
palestinians getting along you play a
palestinian yeah in fact you are jewish
how did you get that accent down because
you do have a very strong accent in the
convincing accident
that's another was that did you have a
coach i did i had uh this he's an actor
too amazing his name was waleed zuwader
and he really
worked because your parents are i mean
this this is going to sound really naive
ignorant excuse me but was it anywhere
close to a moroccan
accent that you were familiar with no
it's such a different thing like i
didn't know arabic at all i heard it my
parents my grandparents could speak a
dialect from morocco but
you know when you're speaking french
it's there's nothing familiar with like
french and arabic
but i did really tune into that sort of
moroccan like the character delia i
really turned into like the hair and the
gold and the energy of where i come from
that the whole thing there's a very
they're very outgoing they they put a
lot out yes exactly and a warmth
for sure and it's you know it was such a
beautiful experience working with waleed
because
we really were like we would get into
these personal conversations and i'd be
like my god we have like if he talked
about his grandmother and i talked about
mine
so similar
do you know like there's a cultural
thing that's there well that's what's
kind of nice about the movie even though
it's this big comedy and like silly
whatever but there is so the message
behind it is kind of like
there's so many there's way more
similarities between these two groups of
people way more than that and very like
ones that you would kind of take for
granted but like the type of women
they're attracted to the jokes that they
laugh at everything
everything the food the way everything
yes you know and i remember we would
have these lunches with you know the the
palestinian actors like authentically
palestinian the israeli actors
and we would have these lunches and we
were like well there you have it we have
figured out
it's right here that easy hey yasser
arafat check it out check this out
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
do you remember why you got into acting
was it always just something you enjoyed
doing were you
it was did somebody look at you and say
you should be doing this a little bit
when i was a kid kid kid get like
four five six
um
you know we would go to these
family things the bar mitzvah wedding or
whatever and i would be there dancing oh
yeah huge family dancing you know
circle around me stage fright
and apparently anxiety kicked in
somewhere along the lines but
but so there was always that and you
know being sort of approaching to do
commercials and that's that the other
and and i always when i was a little
little girl i was like i want to be an
actress and a singer and a dancer and an
artist and like it was anything to do
with the arts and then when i was seven
i did my first play and it was that
experience that changed it for me like i
was like oh that's it this is it was it
like a kid's play or no it was a real
play not a real play not to say that
kids but for all the kids listening
it's a very it was a not a children's
play though i played the baby ghost
it was a drama
and um about a whole family
and i that sense of community really got
me yeah the kai
was totally in my mom was an actress and
so we would my brothers and i know that
yeah yeah wow um my my so my brothers
and i would do occasionally if they
needed like a kid and
she was part of a workshop we would play
one of the like child parts
yeah but i just i remember i wasn't
crazy about acting then but i i liked
the
a lot of the actors the the adults i
remember the adults being very playful
that you know very like kind of fun to
be around yes yeah exactly it was a
great atmosphere it was a great
atmosphere yeah so you so then you start
doing it professionally and is that
because and those are commercials mostly
those are yeah in in toronto in toronto
i really started well i went to high
school for the performing arts oh i
didn't know that yeah in
10th grade
there was so the equivalent i guess of
nickelodeon in
canada it was called ytv
and they had this writing competition
and the winner would have their show
produced and made
so they used our high school
because it was like a new beautiful high
school and then we got to audition
for
the for this show
and speaking of degrassi
one of the girls in my
class
she was like blonde and gorgeous and she
was onto grassy and it was like such a
big deal oh
yeah a huge show it was huge it was like
a big deal so
so we're auditioning and the role was
for um
[Music]
roxanne donovan who was the like
she was like the high school [ __ ] and
like the popular girl i can see that
so everybody was like well
obviously sarah right i was like of
course sarah i was like yeah
and then like whenever i auditioned and
i got it oh no
lee molly and then that
literally started everything that's
crazy that the first professional role
you played was a like [ __ ] yeah that's
shocking isn't that amazing it's so
funny
and i got an agent and all those things
yeah and so at this point you know i'm
16 and then
and then started from like ground zero
like one-liners commercials well there's
a lot of stuff going on in toronto
um so then what why and when did you
move to vancouver and why not move to la
if you're going to move that far west
being canadian trying to get to the
states yes
hell on wheels yeah it's the worst yeah
uh there was a lot of work in vancouver
um and you know that's true there was
there was a ton happening worked a bunch
out there and then finally
got my
working visa and i always thought i'd be
new york based so i went to new york
there were so many things you know i
left canada sort of deeply frustrated
because it really felt like at the time
i was always going to play the friend
like there was
looking the way i looked is that because
you were brunette yeah it almost felt
like canada didn't know what to do with
me in a weird way even though it is so
multicultural
and when i came out to la it was like
the moment i came to l.a i never had a
second job again wow like wow up until
that point you had been waiting tables
100 yeah yeah wow but our passes have
really crossed we i've met
occasionally
i think we met at some point between
waiting right we didn't yeah we didn't
meet on waiting no no
because i knew you when by the time we
got to do that movie for sure for sure
i'm glad you can't remember um that was
15 years ago
there are a lot of people in that movie
i mean ryan reynolds uh reynolds anna
ferris dane kirk the list goes on uh
louise guzman guzman i hope this podcast
sticks around long enough that i get to
have every one of them on
so amazing
we shot that in new orleans was the
first time i've ever been in new orleans
what was your experience like on that
what are your memories of of waiting
waiting yeah oh my god i just remember
yeah like going and
going to new orleans and it was just
like amazing
and no that was my first also
and um this like great cast and playing
like
kyla but like lesbians oh yes he played
a surly lesbian center
with jordan
amazing
it was so random and hilarious and i
remember too because i had auditioned i
think i had auditioned for anna's part
originally okay okay yeah and then you
know whatever they put it all together
and they were like you know come and
play this part and i remember doing that
stupid
which one music video
oh yeah
i think the music video is the best part
of that movie that music video is really
funny i mean i mean it's like it was so
funny all of it was just so crazy and i
just remember having like
great times with all you guys
we had so much again i'm going to sound
like so irresponsible but i i have
regrets about that movie only because
i don't know if regret's the right word
we went out
almost every night i went out almost
again
this is going to be good
i've changed but but it was new orleans
first time in new orleans and this like
young
we were all kind of the same age yeah
oh it was so [ __ ] fun we go out all
the time but we justified it because the
movie took place over the course of it
was set during one day yeah really after
the night of a big party yes so we all
kind of justified going out because like
well our characters would be hungover
we are like we're like method actors
that was amazing do you know how many
comments i get oh yeah of like just
watched waiting i didn't know you were
in waiting
like like
god it's so fun
i get it a lot too and i get it from uh
waiters often times and uh i'm always a
little nervous and they always say it
like they're slight not that they're
embarrassed about it but like they're in
some sort of club because they know they
know them they're like hey i know you're
from waiting yeah yeah we love that
movie and i look i'll look back at the
kitchen staff and they're all like yeah
what's up
but there's always a part of me that's
like oh how much do they relate to this
movie because it's it's really
disgusting a lot of it it's
really yeah there's a running gag where
like they put things in people's food
and so whenever i hear
like pubes and stuff that's just not
like not spicy it's like pork i should
have created terrible yeah
it's a movie that you definitely
couldn't and i i was just doing an
interview for uh this this gay
publication
and they brought up how much has changed
since then in terms of what is
acceptable and and is deemed you know
offensive and
and i forgot at the end of that movie
that movie ends the big like payoff to
the whole john francis daley uh
character um
is he calls everyone or at least ryan
reynolds character he calls him a [ __ ] oh
god yeah and i had forgotten that and um
i think there's some dated stuff in that
movie that they wouldn't be able to do
you know for you know for good reasons
but uh but we but i just discussed so
this guy was telling me all about you
know all the problematic areas of
waiting down i'm like oh yeah it's true
we probably couldn't make that but
yeah exactly i mean but do you know
what's so interesting though i get it
and everything is so you know pc now and
yeah but it's like to the point of like
fear this thing yeah everywhere people
are afraid like people are just scared
and it's like it has to go so extreme it
has to go one way in order to find it
the balance right right because there's
so many good i mean there's so many you
know incredible
sort of and and what's happening there's
a real movement
important change
but i gotta say
i feel
so lucky
that we came up at a time
that we did and that we didn't have
social media at that time
you know like all the way even through
entourage we didn't have that's right
instagram i know when we were doing
entourage you know i'm thinking about
some of those experiences that we had
and i don't know how present i would
have been i don't know that i not to say
going out and drinking every night is
like you know the best way to experience
the world but like
even doing you know going to the isle of
pal we were so present you know so
the experience it was like
it was us we had our
thing it was like a month and a half and
it's like etched into our hearts and
memories forever right now i wonder how
much of it would have been on this i
agree you although i have to say you are
very responsible with it and i like it i
really appreciate that you are and you
you kind of deliver these messages these
very
warm um encouraging
messages like a lot of like shabbat
shalom type stuff how does it fit into
your life that's social media
you know at the beginning of this before
we said
the issues with social media yeah i
think that
straight up i wish it didn't exist yeah
i do yeah i think it's killing our
future generation
i think there's a lot more wrong than
good actually
i really do
um i think in a business sense awesome
great right it took me a really long
time to jump on board and it was that
thing it was like like jump in and swim
or don't i know but at a certain point
like
it it's just not even an option anymore
like if you're on a show you're on a
movie it's in your [ __ ] contract
they're sending you artwork to post at
this time yeah that's you know it's done
yeah so that's how it's done so i had to
really um come to terms
with
okay i need
to raise my numbers and at the same time
i just i can't feel compromised while
doing it it still is you it's a part of
you that you're putting out yeah it's a
part of you that you're putting out
there and i feel like there's so many
aspects of this business where you've
sacrificed so much that you're like okay
this is me this is my brand so
if we are
entertainers
i like to think of ourselves as
light
bringers we bring light to the world
whether it's you know within the films
we do make people laugh maybe people cry
we tell stories we tell important
stories
you know all of those things it was like
okay then i want to be a light then i
want this social media thing to be a
bring awareness for charities that are
important to me
promote the projects
and then i just want to share
what resonates deeply to me like there's
so many like political things that i
just i can't anymore like i just get
saturated where i'm like no that's not
what i want to do unless it's really
truly authentic to me i guess that's the
thing i want to be
authentic
as often as possible yeah well mission
accomplished yeah it's really nice to
follow you and everyone should follow
you it's it's
am shrieky
what's the most commonly mispronounced
version of your name because i think
before i met you i i thought of you as
creepy
emmanuel kriequi
creek
white
shriek white
i don't i don't even know what quiet
like
i often get emmanuel
[Laughter]
i also wish people could have seen that
just er i'm just going to let it go into
space emmanuel's enough right
yeah there's not a lot of
it but it is but now i know that it's
pronounced shri kwaii
no it's tricky right it's shrieky um
uh there was a like two percent of me
that wasn't positive
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet
how do you get entourage and is that the
next is that the thing that kind of
broke you like no but yes but yeah yeah
100 there was absolutely life before
entourage in life after entourage that
was like 2007
yeah ish yeah you play sloan you play
ease
yeah yeah um and it was a role that at
first was more minimal than it became
right it became a very integral part of
the show yeah it was this crazy slow
burn you know originally slow and burn
nice that was such a justinism
i um
i had an audition
and it was a three-episode arc oh no
kidding yeah
and
that and i joined you know whatever
second season so imagine i did the whole
series plus a movie
oh wow which was just this sort of epic
the gift that kept on giving
um but it was such a cool story because
when i auditioned you know originally
the role was this like very sort of
blonde waspy
beverly hills girl i'm supposed to be
the girl you went to school with the
degrassi girl you thought she was always
it always comes back to that
so was snow day by the way oh yeah
gwyneth paltrow type that was i remember
i remember the breakdown and i was like
are you kidding me oh wow that's again
like when i say like being here in the
states really gave me a different
opportunity like people took those
chances and it's funny because now we
like we talk about diversity diversity
and inclusion but it's not it was like
for me it just felt like the just the
girl she just wasn't blonde like sloane
was just like a girl it wasn't like
diversity
it was just true
that's true were you casters were there
so they weren't even looking for it i
mean you said about the other role they
were looking for blonde girl yeah so
often times you get these roles was it
and is it different now is it now like
you get roles that are
looking for some i wouldn't even know
how to explain your ethnicity i don't
mean neither i i'm like i'm a rocky
olive skin yeah i don't mean i don't
even know so long story short entourage
you so you you sign up for three three
episodes i go and audition and
i remember that uh they brought me back
to read with kevin and before they audit
kevin connolly and before the audition
kevin
it asked my agents like can i speak to
her so i was getting mixed messages from
everywhere like
that she wasn't funny enough or like
what based on the audition yeah oh so
was it a fun were they funny signs
it wasn't that at all
at all like at all yeah the girl yeah so
kevin calls me and he's like listen
whatever you heard disregard that do
exactly what you did that's cool she was
amazing and then
didn't hear for weeks and i remember in
the last hour
they
uh
they ended up auditioning um
[Music]
rachel lee cook
and it looked like they were going to go
she was on that she's awesome yeah
and it looked like they were going gonna
go that way oh no and then
kev
was like
no i want her
i want um and doug was like a really big
on my side as well and so kevin called
me through the offer oh man because he
only had so many friends in common and
he was like hey that's kevin carley
so um listen uh i just wanted to let you
know that uh yeah you got the offer
and it was interesting because he had
said to me listen it is three episodes
for now
he said but there's a real possibility
that this could turn into more it's
funny they often say that and it's like
never the case um this was like
unbelievable game changer did he call
rachael cook to let her down
rachel it's kevin
um she
and she's great she would have been
great but you brought something to it
that had was completely different i mean
that's
um
and i and i like that they started
writing more for you i mean that they
they wrote to you to your strengths and
and that you weren't just like the girl
on the show right right had a lot to do
um
how
it's funny i was about to mention i
think the like the fourth podcast that
i've done where i've mentioned sarah
pantera
but is that how you know pantera sir is
that how you know kevin just from going
out from going out yeah yeah that whole
landscape
that's not that he's in lance but no but
that whole crew leo and toby and like
that whole crew
was from going out in back in the day
yeah except that i never knew kev oh
weird you knew all the other members of
the all his other friends the entourage
the wolf back yeah i knew them all but i
never knew kev huh weird yeah so bizarre
so like yeah ethan supply and all of
that
um
uh so now you're on the show now does it
feel like at what point does it feel
like this is gonna be a regular thing
now i'm going to be on this for a while
it never did oh it was always it was
like every year was like
you know and we just sort of started to
clue in and then it suddenly
you know jay was sort of one of those
things where it was like i don't think
any of us realized
how
huge it was until after huh does that
make sense like
yeah you look back at it and like that
was i guess kind of like really
significant but in the moment it was
it was what it was like it was just sort
of one of those things and
also you're shooting around out you're
living in l.a and you're shooting at
these like locations
many of whom you've probably gone to
socially and for sure yeah that's why
the show worked was because it really
was it was a love letter to l.a yeah it
was a real guilty pleasure for me
because i was like these are things that
i shouldn't want to go home and watch
right but it was it was done so well
everybody was so the acting was so good
and uh i was just it was so fun to watch
do you keep in touch with all those guys
are you i keep in touch especially with
kev and with jerry yeah yeah jerry
do you have regrets i i wonder this
because you strike me as somebody who
has dealt with things in a very healthy
way you mentioned you had a really awful
year
you don't strike me as somebody who
carries on to things holds on to things
um
i try not to i mean but i
i definitely struggle with it you do for
sure i think i think the struggles are i
think when you especially you're going
through a dark time or a hard time like
you know what jay i'm pretty certain
that when i'm older
i'll look back on these days and wish
that i didn't spend
so much time agonizing
so much time god i can't believe you do
living with
you know a certain amount of anxiety
um where
you know at different times has been
like debilitating like where where i
don't see people or like where i won't
go out or that i'm
you know somewhat self-destructive
smoking way too much like doing things
that weed or cigarettes
both yeah you know so
so so i think but i think that that's
my
journey yeah and i think it's like um
i think it ebbs and flows and i think
there are good days there are bad days
there are good weeks there are bad weeks
and there are some years that really
stick out as like whoa and that last
year was one of those last year was a
[ __ ]
whoa well i i i want to know about it
but i guess the most important part of
it is that you're
coming out of it now yeah
yeah good
and i think that all that is it's
perfectly imperfect it's part of the
transition it's part of the
transformation well you're somebody who
as long as i've known you you've had
tragedy in their lives and i got to know
you and i really admired you for the way
you
would dealt with those things in your
life at the death of your mother at 16
and then
the last time i saw you was not long
after your dad had died and again i
i was so struck by how you were able to
process that and i'm sure it's something
you're still processing and you know
it's weird to compliment somebody on
something like that but you
i really admired your strength so lovely
you were such a good friend to me i
remember after two when my dad was sick
and you would send me like these amazing
texts do you remember those texts that
you would send me like checking in yeah
he was sick for a while
yeah and you just sent me you know and i
get strength from all of that it's not
i get do you have a core group of
friends that yeah i do and they're kind
of like they must be like your family
100 you know i think at a certain point
as you well know i think as we get older
it becomes less about quantity and more
about quality totally totally yeah and
the time i mean that's one of the
reasons this show's called life is short
i like the reminder and
and the time has become so much more
precious it's funny i i look back it's
the only regrets that i do have and i
guess they are regrets is some of the
relationships or some of the
the nights out where i feel like i sort
of wish i had sat with myself a little
bit more and appreciated what was
happening to me um
instead of
chasing these relationships and stuff um
these are really quick um
what is your most commonly used emoji
kissy face oh yeah yeah i've been using
that a lot lately kissy face or the one
with the girl the girl but it's like oh
[Laughter]
uh yeah that's funny
the kissy face comes in handy yeah the
one with the heart coming out yes so
cute um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
basketball oh you like basketball yeah
have you ever played a little bit no
please
i mean i love it
i played like you know now i know you
haven't when you just did that i played
you know like in the neighborhood no
no but i love it yeah i love it yeah um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life
when snack food when snack food when you
get really snacky wink wink wink wink
i'm drawing a blank on snacky it used to
be like nutella
it's not at all anymore i would have to
say snacky chips okay salt and vinegar
salt and vinegar potato chips
run through a bag oh
um what it but yeah i get it i totally
get it what's your favorite movie of all
time if you have one i'll give you top
three yeah good
shawshank redemption oh jacob's ladder
andy dufresne was my friend
uh the best friend i love the way he
says friend oh god
and and andy dufresne was my friend
friend friend a workshop
um and
one of my earliest memories that like
struck me in my heart that i like died
over for
a week straight couldn't stop crying
the mask do you remember that mask was
share oh my god it's so funny i thought
you were talking about the jim carrey
movie
yes sure yeah she remember being so
young and so deeply affected by that
yeah uh other than l.a where would you
most want to live
somewhere in europe
i don't know probably paris
okay i like the way you said that it was
a very parisian way to say that
probably paris
london
um yeah if you could have dinner with
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met
gandhi um
do you think about the other side and
you see you're very spiritual person do
think about the other side i struggle
with it still i don't have a peaceful
relationship with death yet that's but i
really
i really struggle with that yeah it it
actually really does scare me i think my
it's not so much a regret a regret
question but
jay like i
something
so real
that i think about all the time
is like this feeling of like
i want i need to live life to the
fullest
and so i guess
when i don't feel like i'm doing that
that's a regret right and if you have
angry you have anger about it i get
anxiety yeah yeah
yeah because you know how
quickly it can go yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um okay sorry that that got that good so
three people oh yeah okay so gandhi i
would say uh which is nice at dinner
because he probably won't eat a lot yeah
he'll be fasting
um i would say wait dead or alive um
oh you know i would have loved to have
um
nelson mandela
and i would say
one you know what like a singer like
either
the baja men
or a baja man no you know you know who
oh [ __ ] jim morrison oh whoa that's a
hell of a dinner
whoa yeah yo yeah you gotta keep the
booze away from me crazy booze and drugs
stay awake
um that would be a crazy dinner uh
i want to see that show
yeah the reality show
um we'll pitch it to bravo uh who was
your favorite muppet
or were you a big muppet girl grown up
um a little bit yeah but not enough to
be like i think
miss piggy uh-huh the entertainer she's
so cute yeah she's cute
there are cuter muppets they're right i
mean kermit was cute too but
no i would say gonzo's cuter
yeah
the cookie one oh cookie monster yeah
you know who actually my favorite it's
not a muffit but you'll know this my
fave fave fave
with snuffalophys
oh
sesame street of course
um it was also so frustrating remember
it was like he's right there
just missed him yeah i remember being a
kid and being like [ __ ] if you would
come seconds earlier it was so
frustrating if you could have either
super x-ray vision or super hearing
which would you choose super x-ray super
hearing uh super hearing
um
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life physically
which would you pick
41.
wow great i'll be that in i was that a
month ago i turned that
um how do you get out of us you you are
so
sweet you were so kind to people
what do you do when you get pissed off
do you ever run into people and you
think oh [ __ ] i don't want to talk to
them i have to lie and get out of this
social situation
what do you i mean with guys and stuff
right yeah yeah yeah well first of all
i'm a
master deflector ah
i can deflect oh yeah like easy and if
somebody's hitting on me and i'm like oh
god
how do i get myself out of this i can
just
flip it yeah like like flip it okay
you're like
flippy for real
let's say you're in line at a coffee
shop and you some guy's just giving in
and and he's like hey um you kind of
know him you don't want to talk to him
and he he's like i wish i could stay in
chitchat but you know i got i gotta run
and then he doubles back and he goes you
know what [ __ ] that other thing i got a
solid half hour let's sit down and talk
what do you do
and you've already said oh too bad it'd
be nice to fake you'd be nice to hang
out oh i was already fake yeah you were
already like not fake but like oh too
bad you have to go knowing me i would be
like oh my god you know what
i would have loved to but the truth is i
can't right now why because i actually
do have to go oh you do i thought you
because you had said i know
what are you doing where are you going
i'll go with you
no
oh god i'm so glad it wasn't something
you've said to me in the past
like wait a minute you told me that you
had a concert you forgot about
um beetles or stones
stones really
i don't know no no no no wrong answer no
i don't know how challenging no i don't
think so but just when you said that i
was like oh actually do i mean that no i
guess beatles you listen to a lot of
like hip-hop that yeah i always feel
like really left out when you so you
know all of you know all the words and
you move really well i'm just thinking
about the last time we hung out and i
was like oh cool
like i like it i like your the vibes but
um
it's um what this is i hate to end on a
morbid note but um there's a theme uh
what would you want your epitaph to read
do you want to be buried
i'd rather be cremated i think
that i was a wildly brilliant light
well i would second that i would agree
with that i hope i don't see that
because that would mean that i was still
alive and uh
i um
i wanted today's mother's day and it
must be weird for you it must be a hard
day it's not it's not any more funny
yeah yeah
well i wish your mom i think she'd be
really really like who you became i
think she'd really
make me cry no it's true you're one of
the kindest you are a light and
i'm i'm so grateful to know you and to
be a pal and maybe thank you thanks for
doing this oh my god i love you so much
and i'm so
happy that we got this time
and we're gonna have more i know we
should start recording this in fact
every time um thanks thank you
[Music]
oh okay well
oh man
that happened that just happened yeah i
wish it was still happening because
she's just
i just really
i'm fond of her you sure are and it's
pretty obvious oh wait is it in a bat no
no not in a weird way
now you know what's funny i we were
justin and i on the way to the studio to
do the interview
we stopped off
for a massage oh yeah and uh it sounds
very romantic we did like a couple's
massage well we didn't massage each
other no but we were right it's like
when you go with your significant other
to get a massage you kind of have you
ever done that yeah you lie right next
to them and they so it's like it's like
tandem massage and that's kind of what
we did we were right next to each other
and they're like massaging us yeah yeah
i've done that a few times i feel a
little s i know on the bachelor they're
always like let's have a romantic
couples massage i don't know but it's
weird it's like two
personal things it's a very personal
thing but also but not with your partner
you're being touched by strangers it is
weird it's weird in this case i'm glad
we did it only because i want two
reasons one because it felt amazing and
uh but two
your post massage energy oh yeah worked
perfectly
with her energy which is i would say
always post massage she has like yes her
normal energy is post massage energy
yeah i have that energy for like maybe
30 maybe 30 40 minutes afterwards by the
end of the interview you were like all
high strong and crazy i miss you so much
um yeah do you remember the time um
you're right you're totally right she
has this very calm
it's amazing to me was that a good
emmanuel shirt she's pretty good
she has such good energy and she has
such a calm i hate when people say this
but like a vibe she's such
like like a cool like mellow
comfortable vibe so she's so nice to be
around i think that word is overused to
describe people and i you i overuse it
energy vibe i usually do in a jokey way
but i think it's overused because most
people don't have a clear energy or vibe
hers is so
inviting and all good things like
enveloping it like she like envelops you
with this energy she has good vibes good
good energy energy good vibe like beyond
good just like
it's kind of special it's like
therapeutic yes
you feel like you're getting a
personality massage when you're around
her because it's like she makes you feel
so comfortable like you've had a
treatment like an energy treatment just
by hanging out with her you know she and
and i remember one of the most
remarkable things about her
given that given her like
warm beautiful energy is that she went
through such and we don't get that into
it but
i remember really being stunned um by
that news uh about her parents yeah
when i when i first met her her dad was
still alive and she was
so close with him i mean
and the fact that he then got sick and
passed away at an early age but her mom
died at a very early age and and to have
contended with that when she was a
teenager is and
we've talked about this before people's
resilience and how i really admire that
you know we're facing our our own
parents are fortunately still alive but
i know we both think a lot about them
not being alive and how we would
handle that um well i mean to that end
she said um which i really
i really thought was honest and i i
could very much relate to it when she
said um that she doesn't have a peaceful
relationship with death yet she said
that
and um
and i thought
not only was that honest and something
i'm sure a lot of people could relate to
um but
it's there's something really
um hopeful about it too saying
i don't have it yet but i'm still
working on it and i and i'm admitting
that you're scared about it but then
also saying
kind of alluding to the fact that one
day you want not to be scared of it and
it's a process and uh i i you know of
all the guests we've had who have talked
about death in the afterlife uh i found
her
take on that
the most similar to how i how i am and
how uh kind of i aspire to be like
hopeful hopeful but but i can admit that
i'm scared yeah you know
yeah she was um i also she has such um
because of how she presents herself and
how
you know wonderful warm and calm and all
the things we said she is
and the things that i think people can
hear she is i mean that's not an act
like that is her um
i was very surprised when she
pushed back a little bit at i just
assumed she had a wonderful childhood
right when she said her mom had a temper
that surprised me because i can't
imagine
her her getting i mean i'm of course she
does everyone gets mad everyone like has
a temper but i can you imagine emanuel
getting
like
mad at someone or like yelling at
someone she is no i feel like her her
way of dealing with frustration or anger
is if i had to guess is probably
very subdued and measured and okay yeah
let's talk about it you know it was
almost like she was born in such a
peaceful environment like you know you
hear stories about
they tell
people
mothers about water birth like giving a
water birth because the idea is the baby
gets born into this there's a calming
transition you know from the amnio
amniotic fluid life that they lived into
another water
so it's not they're not coming out into
the [ __ ] that light and like yeah like
here he is like a bunch of like weird
big people like cutting your tubes and
it's a more calming introduction to the
world she strikes me as like her first
week was just in this in the she was
born into like in some yurt and right
with like you picture her parents
wearing like just playing like pan
flutes like drapery like draped
drapey clothing yeah and like dancing
together and like like a midwife playing
a sitar
you know like
yeah and you're like you're like
positive you're like positively uh
stereotyping her yeah yeah like she
seems like she was from a great yeah and
again as a trend so nothing's perfect
exactly so then it's almost like
more it says more about her and her
resilience that she
was able to
deal with that and process it and come
out the other side being as
kind and gentle as she is i think says a
lot about marvel yeah
you guys talked you
you've talked quite a bit on the show
about uh the movie waiting and
and um and your memories well because we
you've had you know a lot of positive
memories from it but but you tell
throughout the course of this interview
you tell so many boozy stories it's like
you talk about patriot bill
like working with her on that movie in
south carolina you talk about being
hungover on broadway you talk about
your fun in new orleans doing waiting
god you're like
it was it was a lot i kind of hope that
my mom doesn't figure out how to listen
to the show how to stream how to stream
the show i'm painting i know you're like
orson welles you're like
but you actually weren't i mean i i i
can attest to the fact that tom sizemore
you definitely like to go out but you
but you like you drunk or like you
partying is relatively speaking very
tame like yeah your personality you're
one of those drinkers who like you get
more up and you like meeting people and
you occasionally like busting tables at
restaurants but um but you're basically
you you're just like you with more
energy yeah we have you don't change
when you're drinking the reason that
i've really like to change that kind of
behavior is because physically my body
can't handle it the next day
i still have fun when i drink but but
the next day is lost for me and i hate
as you know i hate wasting any time and
like because the days have gotten more
precious
the idea of wasting one because like i
drank too much and to what end like
so anyway i've
i don't really do that anymore but back
then my body could process it and so i
could be a little drunk have fun and the
next day i was able to function oh my
god remember how easy it was i remember
being in college and
and going out drinking and then the next
morning having to go to the having to i
say having to go to the football game uh
because we housed in an acapella group
as you all know
and we and we would go to the football
games the tailgates before the football
games that started at like 9 00 a.m and
the school serenade contracted us to go
around these different groups of people
partying tailgating and like
yeah and sing for them get out of here
most of whom
these people were like ugh god these
like 13 is here
but and we knew it was annoying but we
had to do it because we had this
contract with the school
so there was always an element of like
you know that sorry guys but like this
we'll only do two songs and we did but
we couldn't say that because we we
wanted to represent songs would you
serenade them it was like goodbye my
coney is get out of here yeah
i'm not kidding but anyway my only point
in saying this is i would go out the
night before and drink
and then the next morning at like 8 30
have you have to wake up and like have a
couple beers the tail and like like
nothing had happened you know your body
just recovers so easily back then mr
sandman yes
enjoy the game guys uh i remember
feeling so bad did you wear outfits like
little uh barbecue yes we wore jeans and
white button-down shirts and colgate
belts that was our outfit oh my god yeah
i'm sorry
mama mia oh boy um we'll cut all that
out
uh you call watching entourage a guilty
pleasure you refer to as you refer to it
as a guilty pleasure and i was wondering
if that's insulting it is um i don't
know though
does guilty pleasure imply that that the
pleasure is something you're not i guess
that's what it means
the way i meant it was because uh not
that it's a bad it was considered a
guilty pleasure the most it's to me
because i to me because i was kind of
living not that life but a version of
that life you know a virgin of that life
yeah in fact we
there we had a lo there was like we were
in a little nerd i mean it's to call
what we had an entourage is really
insulting to entourages but
uh
you know i'm not saying we had a cool
entrepreneur right but it was uh
that show was
i think both really good and well made
but also
appealed to a more guilty thing because
the content of it was like
like it was hidden a lot of it was very
hedonistic it was like this guy like
meeting girls like partying and
and and things that are kind of like you
know people read about in tabloids so i
think that's the guilty part of it the
content was guilty yeah and and having
seen it recently it's like it's very
revealing not having seen it in like a
number of years i mean maybe 10 years
it's been since i watched enter now
considering culturally how much has
changed and how
the landscape is you know the the the
con
the landscape of creative content has
changed the point where like
most of those episodes you can't do and
i'm not saying
that's a good thing or a bad thing i i i
think it's you know the changes have
been really positive and and uh but but
it's dated i guess my point is like a
lot of that stuff the guilty stuff is
it's extra guilty now when you see it
through it from a 20 through a 2019 lens
sure um they're hooking up and like with
girl i mean there's a lot of that um it
was funny that she at one point you said
that you're now on instagram and you
you're like i have 400 followers and she
thought you meant before you didn't know
this in the moment but after the
interview oh yeah it i forget how it
came up but but uh she had when you said
i 400 followers she thought assumed you
meant 400 000. yes i'm so glad you
brought that and she said and but so in
the interview you're like yeah i have
400 interviews i have 400 followers and
because you had just started this
instagram page so you literally had 400
followers
and she was like oh and she she was like
oh it's so cool congrats that's really
cool and so she thought you were
bragging about having 400 000
followers so she wrote she must have
thought it was so douchey of you yeah so
i'm glad we were able to clear up that
miscommunication afterwards you're like
no i don't mean 400 000 i mean 400 i
would never brag about having 400 000 oh
my god so in the mo yeah you're right in
the moment i'd be like and not only did
i brag about it but i did it in like a
humble braggy way where i was like
yeah i only have four i only like i know
she was like congrats yeah so oh oh
gross isn't it so like just knowing that
even in that moment she thought that you
were bragging about it is so like
gives you douche chills yeah i love when
you comb douche chills when you you see
somebody wearing like yeah that was fun
that's a funny term you were doing your
morgan and your morgan freeman
impression and andy dufresne and you and
i thought for a second you would never
stop doing it oh you repeated it so many
you were like because i was trying to
work it out in my sometimes i do an
impression it doesn't sound right to me
and i have to like kind of find the
voice
i did it a lot
so funny and she uh finally and andy
dufresne okay i once had a friend it's
actually pretty good my friend andy doof
your face looks crazy how you're doing
yeah i know i know it's not a good
impression to do on a date uh she said
she loves for many reasons she said she
loves the mask and was so moved by it
emotionally and
for the record it's called mask
not the mask you don't think about the
gymkhana mask it's a jim carrey movie
mask is a move cher and eric stilt
and i when she said that it was so funny
to imagine her getting moved like
emotionally moved by jim carrey in the
mask
i'm glad that we settled that
yeah that's really funny
uh but but that's it i thought it was it
was really nice to be around her and to
see her again
yeah really it's been a long time yeah
it's been yeah it's been
do you want to read a letter from uh one
of our fans one of our fans i can't
believe i just said that oh can we cut
that out
no no [ __ ] michelle don't cut that
um oh god i'm like i just gave i just
gave myself douche i know why is that so
douchey to say a friend yeah it just is
it just is listen what is that your
stomach i know i'm just farting ew
sorry will it won't make it to you
uh this is from alex g he says hello
hello justin and christian
since i was seven or eight years old i'm
now 26 i've been in love with video
games i had a cousin that did video game
review articles for a newspaper in
wisconsin and that was my confirmation
that i could do something that made
playing video games a living when i
listened to the life short episode with
jb smoove i decided to start doing my
dream job
he said that you have to at least try to
do something that you have passion for
and it really hit me so
so i'm going to renovate my garage into
an office and start live streaming and
creating youtube content while working
55 hours a week at a welding job and 20
hours a week as a youth pastor at a
church oh my god it'll be hard and that
he didn't say oh my god he's a youth
pastor it'll be hard and that's what
i've been afraid of i know i will be
good at it though and i realize that
every year is the new shortest year of
your life
when you think of years as fractions of
a hole that's depressing i know but kind
of good to remind yourself keep in mind
i am going to dive in and your podcast
has sparked my passion again thank you
justin oh that's really nice really nice
it's also i i remember how inspiring jb
smoove was it so it makes sense if
anyone's gonna uh you know
kick-start someone's yeah motivation jb
smoove is a good person to do that like
i don't i don't i can't really take
credit for that i don't think you know
jb
i think he might he i think alex g
mentored thank you jb but he he wrote
thank you justin it's probably an
autocrat thank you jl yeah did i say l
um yeah he was inspiring inspiring
anybody who's that uh
positively passionate you know is
inspired that was really nice to hear
i'm glad that jb made some difference
did you ever meet people and you're like
you could tell me any book
recommendation diet recommendation and i
just so respect however you're living
your life like what you've done you seem
to have just figured it out if keanu
reeves told me to do just about anything
i probably might if he said you know i i
actually like to put
leeches on my wrists in the morning for
about a half an hour i just get the
blood he did wouldn't even need an
explanation like yeah what would keanu
do what would kevin bacon do well yeah
let's not get back into that that's true
uh well that's not let's not get back
into that so if you have god if you guys
want to write in we'd love to hear from
you
write in about anything specifically we
would love to hear how you make the most
out of your
lives you can reach us at do people say
that about email you can reach us
email you can e-meet us uh yeah i hate
that term you meet us at uh i've used it
though
you have to use it there's another way
of saying it nice to meet you you guys
can reach us at uh you can e-meet us at
life is short at wondering.com so so
that's it thanks alex g thank you thanks
emmanuel shariq c
e c
oh yeah ec those are well no we'll i
call her m okay and so if alex g is alex
g she's m c got it
and c shrieks that's a good name for her
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
thank you for listening to life is short
if you enjoyed the show uh please give
us a five star review and tell your
friends to subscribe
uh we're available on apple podcast
spotify google podcast and google google
and uh where else anywhere you listen to
podcasts and wondering.com life is short
is hosted by me justin long it's
produced by me
christian long and megan monaco michelle
miche lanz is our senior producer our
engineer is marcelino viabando it's
executive produced by marshall louis and
ernan lopez for wondering our theme song
is performed by our friend armor
superstar
[Music]
he was you do your best bobcat cultivate
in police academy impression i like it
oh wait hold on
what should i say give me something um
say i thought i was working the
afternoon shift okay um i gotta try to
remember it
i thought i was working the afternoon
oh my god that's terrible um
yeah i used to be able to do it really
well i haven't heard it until
i use that i think it was running after
youtube but i don't know i know i don't
know
i don't remember it it's really hard to
do it's hard i
used to do it all the time
i use it i i use it i think i use it all
the time and now i don't
i hate to do it all the time and he
sounds like harmar
no i don't even know he'd like go into a
like a roar yeah
it's a little like jiminy glick
because he would like to make like i
guess and then he goes down there it's
sort of like
[Music]
short
you